yeah believe it or not there are I mean
and there are four people in the book
who use their last breath to cheer for
their favorite football team
hi I'm Nick Gillespie for reason TV
today we're talking to Robert K elder
author of last words of the executed Rob
thanks for coming thanks for having me
Nick what is your what's your goal with
publishing the book which is a
collection of final words from the
people are being put to death
essentially it's it's really a
non-political goal my central question
the driving question was if these are
the most dangerous reviled members of
society why does it remain a cultural
value to record what they say no okay
well let's look at a couple of examples
because this is an incredible survey of
you know hundreds of years worth of
American executions Sarah Goode
convicted of witchcraft in the
Massachusetts Bay Colony in 1692 she
says I am no more a witch than you are a
wizard and if you take away my life God
will give you blood to drink what do you
make of that I included it because it
was one of the most vitriolic you know
she's obviously mad she was a very
strong personality I didn't include all
the quotes I found in the book because
on these shores since 1608 16,000 people
have been executed so this is sort of a
smattering of those and i chose ones
that were compelling that show
personality and some life experience
well iftar and the end of life
experience right yes a good head also
she had been involved in in the aunt
Hutchinson trial and what not a great
act of dissent in colonial America what
who recorded her words or where did they
appear I think they just come from court
records and Diaries I mean it's a it's a
mix especially with the early ones
because last words were sometimes
recorded and published in pamphlets as
sort of spiritual guides to dignify
dying and sometimes they're our
newspaper accounts right well let's go
to 1977 a very famous execution it
really got the ball rolling again in
1977 Gary Gilmore his final word were
words were let's do it what what's going
on there well he was the first execution
after the more
torium in 1977 and the first by firing
squad and he requested a fire yeah and
you tie you could choose and in fact
it's against the law now they no longer
execute people by firing squad except
for the people who were condemned before
that law so for example Ronnie Lee
Gardner will be executed i believe it's
scheduled for june eighteenth of this
this month today the immediate entry
before Gary Gilmore is James Roger
another Utah execution from 1960 he's
asked if he had any last requests and he
says why yes a bulletproof vest yes is
there a lot of this is I guess it's like
gallows humor it's [ __ ] it's not get
actual its actual gallows humor yeah
yeah believe it or not there are I mean
and there are four people in the book
who used their last breath to cheer for
their favorite football team Wow who
who's the favor uh two Raiders one
cowboys and one Cleveland Browns do you
think that did that worked out into the
promotional materials for those clubs I
don't I don't I don't know and it's
clear that the last Browns fan that was
was then executed right yes yes yes uh
karla faye tucker who famously was the
first woman executed in texas since i
believe just after the Civil War she was
involved in I guess a double murder
where she and her boyfriend brutally
pickaxe people to death she famously
said that she had an orgasm every time
she swung the axe into the body her last
words are yes sir I would like to say
thank you thanks to all of you the
Thornton family Jerry DS family that I
am so sorry I hope God will give you
peace with this baby i love you Ron give
Peggy a hug for me everybody has been so
good to me I love all of you very much
cetera I love all of you very much i
will see you all when you get there I
will wait for you one of the things that
I found interesting I mean there's a
level of benally here to be quite honest
how does that you know is that common
the sort of ritual of either apologizing
to victims or victims families and you
know saying goodbye to people by name is
actually sort of new
because especially early executions they
were in front of a crowd so there was a
sense of oration it was an event but as
executions became more and more of a
private event behind prison walls that
became more intimate and you have people
directly addressing people on the other
side of the glass so yeah I mean there's
that element to it what you know what's
your hope in terms you said this is not
a political book but what how do you
want this to enter intersect with death
you know death penalty discourse sure
well I really did want to make it a
non-political book just because if you
have an opinion on one side of the issue
of the other you know you're just
publishing for the choir basically I
really wanted to talk about this in
cultural terms and just sort of make it
make people think about death penalty
and again this ritual you know why what
can we learn why do we still keep them
what are you pro or anti death penalty
I'm doing my best to sort of just keep
that can we well kept so you don't want
to say or do you know I'm actually
neutral I mean it's a true journalistic
position now the overall frame of the
book and I say this is somebody who's a
postal death penalty I don't think that
the state should have the right to take
a life I mean they should protect people
by walling dangerous people away but
you've got a foreword by Studs Terkel
who curiously died two years ago so
unfortunately is one of my webbing it's
a great final word from him yeah one of
my regrets is he was he's so supportive
of the project but he didn't get to see
it ultimately but then you have sister
Helen Prejean from the author of dead
man walking and you have the executive
director of the Center on wrongful
convictions I mean is this an anti-death
penalty book ultimately from my
perspective no but and when we were
asking for people to weigh in those are
the only people that responded but no
it's really not an anti-death penalty
book in fact folks who are anti-death
penalty I've gotten a little bit of
flack for including sort of more
information on cases that a recent that
were traditionally liberal causes for
example Sacco and Vanzetti
you know while I include a little note
that says you know this is among the 39
cases that the center on wrongful
convictions says you know they're
probably innocent or there's enough
evidence for reasonable doubt I also
include the fact that in 2005 and a
letter from Upton Sinclair surfaced in
which he said he talked to their lawyer
who admitted making up the whole thing
and ginning they're out there alibis
right do you are we in the twilight of
the of the death penalty in America
because there has been a huge amount of
notoriety of people who are on death row
who were who have been exculpated by
genetic evidence or whatever executions
seem to be going down from where they
had been for all sorts of reasons is the
death penalty really being relegated to
history you know I don't know I every
time you know I've been touring the East
Coast and I have people tell me on
either side of the issue it's going away
or we're not one of the most interesting
things that I'm finding is that states
are prosecuting fewer death penalty
cases because they're so expensive it's
become a fiscal issue that's been the
most amazing thing because you know it's
cheaper for them to put somebody in life
or prison and I'm not even talking about
like the actual cost I'm talking the
cost of prosecuting them okay well maybe
that's as it should be right i mean if
this is it's the most serious decision
of staying in my crack well i want to
thank Rob Robert K elder author of last
words of the executed for talking to
reason TV thanks
I